[Musica]
prima
lo stand
hp e rim no
[Musica]
ne va mai la wine someone like you
questa bimba mm ed è spento st fare e da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono papi j
ed oggi siamo in un nuovo blog oggi se
riusciamo ragazzi dovrebbe riuscire a
fare un blog tranquillo senza nulla di
straordinario quindi minear è il chievo
a senza strano ragazzi perché di solito
in ogni blog aggiungo due miliardi di
cosa che non centrano una mazza di
niente
invece stavolta dovrebbe riuscire
abbastanza tranquillo prima di
cominciare tutto ragazzi come al solito
partiamo con l'apparato della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
jasmine che ha fatto questo disegno
fantastico a dir la verità c'è uno
sguardo un po morto ma per tutto il
resto è molto molto carina sono tipo
così io
[Musica]
passando alle news ragazzi penso che la
più evidente diciamo ni tutte sia il
fatto che stiamo per arrivare ad un
traguardo veramente incredibile ovvero
200 mila iscritti che se tutto va bene
dovremmo riuscire a raggiungere entro
fine settimana prossima comunque il vino
speciale per il 200 mila iscritti sia
che li superiamo un po prima si sa che
li superiamo un po dopo uscirà impreciso
st fatto 5 ottobre quindi sabato
prossimo non vi livello che cos'è anche
se comunque l'avete capito chi meno
tutti perché
non vi dico un cazzo perché sono gli
spoiler o compiere cambiamento è fatto
sapere di recente che è uscito un nuovo
dlc per samsung simulator dove devi
operare praticamente un alieno una roba
del genere che andrò a fare di sicuro
nei prossimi giorni quindi ragazzi
preparatevi perché sarà epico detto
questo volevo anche ringraziarmi per il
fatto che mi è piaciuto moltissimo
scrive la usa mess2 che nuovo appunto
scribblenauts è uscito qualche giorno fa
e quindi ragazzi lo continuerò nei
prossimi giorni ovviamente oltre
all'essere normali che faccio di solito
comunque era che ha voglia arrivare al
punto 3 o buono a favero l'ho scartato
dei pacchi ragazzi come ben sapete io i
fatti che mi arrivano li metto sulla
mensola e ad ogni blog i ragazzi io
dicevo che scarto principalmente più
grandi perché mi occupano decisamente
troppo spazio quindi ragazzi potente
dedurre che se sono arrivato al punto 3
così fretta e perché c'è qualcosa di
anomalo voi dovete spiegare che cazzo è
questo dunque ragazzi in questo vito
foglio aprirne 2 ovvero questo qui è
questo qua che sono i fatti che ho da
più tempo o affini ragazzi di lei di
procedere prima con più piccolo e poi
andiamo a vedere che razza di roba è
quella di prima amo aprire i pacchi
ragazzi è bellissimo perché non si sa
perché cazzo c'è dentro soltanto l'unico
problema è che ogni cazzo di blog
si è rotto coltello porca [ __ ]
ragazzi non c'è che cazzo come ha fatto
a rompersi coltello ma mio dio cioè noi
vi dovete spiegare come cazzo ha fatto a
rompersi il coltello sino ai ragazzi non
sto smaterializzando sto pacco quante
cazzo di roma c'è qui dentro c'è mi
sembra vi sembra di avere aperto uno
scrigno del tesoro di quelli di z allora
ho trovato una fa bella ma che cazzo ci
ragazzi adesso già adesso c'è la favella
prima c'era la fa vitella e adesso c'è
la favella certo llamo lettere ogni
volta per cambiare il nome cioè mio
avvio grazie mille brani inviato
l'ennesimo barattolo di nutella come se
non ce ne avesse abbastanza di stoffa mi
avete inviato un piccoli brividi ma
ragazzi perché e c'è ancora qualcosa che
mi ma questo basta in assoluto regalo
più figo di tutti questo lo desiderava
da secoli
oh mio dio purtroppo è sempre stato il
mio sogno avere un topo pupazzo e
fantastico ragazzi e con ragazzi di lei
di passare al secondo pacco quindi a
questo che è dieci volte più grande di
tutti gli altri
io non ho veramente i dati che cazzo ci
possono aver messo qui dentro ma sarà
assurdo ok ci siamo ragazzi devi pronti
non ci posso credere che cosa etica o
mio dio
questa è letteralmente un quadro mio
addio questo l'appello la vuoi che parte
perché è epico si sa ci siamo io che
smario slider e la la cosa unica esempi
di sto quadro e come tengo che mario in
modo amorevole pensare cosa che mi piace
di più temibili vedete come come felice
come siamo felici tutti e due mi piace è
bravissima ma dei ragazzi ci sono ancora
un casino di pacchi che devo aprire e o
seriamente paura comunque ragazzi direi
di passare affari risponde perché questa
settimana avevo delle domande è
fantastica ai quali rispondere e vorrei
iniziare ragazzi non da un commento ma
da un messaggio che ho ritrovato nei
vecchissimi archivi che avevo screen
gatto tempo fa è il messaggio dice ciao
mi puoi sponsorizzare il campo va bene
credi nator fi risponderci fai la
piccola clip mentre fai flessioni
addominali e sollevamento pesi insieme a
chieti mario ok
[Musica]
ma gli risponde pari mi spieghi come fai
a fare i video di just dance quattro
senza che tua madre più vicini si
prendono per fatto a dir la verità
quando io gioca just dance vengo la
finestra aperta perché esageratamente fa
un caldo bestiale e ragazzi
effettivamente io ho sempre paura che
qualcuno possa vedermi da fuori perché
c'è la stupidità è che io non mi
vergogno a farmi vedere davanti a 200
mila persone ma mi vergogno a farmi
vedere da magari un cristiano che
passati fuori quindi se devo essere
sincera un po di strizza me la prendo
quando registrano just dance ma vabbè
chissenefrega gioca all'esorcista si
dice che è senza accento il più senza
cento horror del mondo spolli chat e per
farli e lo leggere alla premetto che
forse sono io che non capito eh ma
comunque come cazzo fai a giocare un
film va bè ragazzi direi che forse
concludere qui con le domande spero che
il blog vi sia piaciuto
sabato prossimo ovviamente come vi ho
detto prima uscirà lo speciale 200 mila
iscritti i ragazzi spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto come al solito se vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come nani
video trovate nella descrizione
se desideri skipping iscrivetevi nei cd
vediamo il prossimo video dai ragazzi